hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll it's
a well-known Trope that there is a
connection between music and Mathematics
it's never quite made sure what exactly
this connection is but certainly
scientists love music as a general rule
Albert Einstein very famously was a
violinist and so forth I think that
there's more to it than just the idea
that math involves numbers or counting
right I mean that's certainly part of it
you have a time signature you have
certain numbers of Beats certain numbers
of notes per measure and so forth but it
goes more deep than that I think that
there is not just a mathematics of music
but there is a theory of music I mean
this is not my idea right there's a
whole field of study called music theory
I guess my point is that scientists love
Theory even experimental scientists love
the idea that there is something out
there in the world that we can think
about in a systematic way talk about it
understand why it works the way it does
and music apps absolutely falls into
that category so today's episode we're
very happy to have Rick biato on the
show Rick has become famous on YouTube
where you probably have seen him many of
you have seen him he started out as a
musician as a music Professor he's
taught at places like the Berkeley
College of Music and as a music producer
but then he started making these videos
on YouTube where he first started by
explaining music theory explaining
chords and progressions and so forth two
people on YouTube
and then he applied his knowledge of
Music Theory and music production to
explaining popular music why certain
songs work my favorite subset in his
YouTube videos is the series called what
makes this song great and to me like
even though it's about music this is
quintessentially mindscaping material
because it's taking something we all
know about we all experience music and
it's trying to understand it at a deeper
level it's not just this song is great
it's what makes this song great and you
dive into why this chord progression
goes the way it does why this change of
tempo or this change of mode is
effective in this particular place and
as we talk about on this episode there's
a connection between the psychology of
music and the science of it right
certain things are very well known to
cause certain emotional reactions this
chord change will make you sad you know
this key is very upbeat why is that and
part of it is you know we don't know but
from the practice point of view it's
just fascinating how we can take these
different ingredients and put them
together to cause an effect and then of
course Rick also has opinions and he
shares knowledge about questions like
why is there a certain chord progression
that seems to dominate all of popular
music and he has very interesting
insights to the extent that it doesn't
need to be that way this is a choice
that the music industry has made so he's
a great explainer of things in a way
that is perfectly suited to this
audience so I think that this is an
episode that everyone is really going to
like even if it's a tiny bit of a
departure from our usual Affair so let's
go
[Music]
thank you
Rick piatto welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks Sean appreciate it so I
have to ask a semi-personal question to
start here like if 10 years ago someone
had said oh yeah you're going to be a
very successful YouTube Star but you
even have known what that meant would
that would that have been in your scope
of possibilities no uh the only thing I
used YouTube for was to send videos to
my mom so of my kids that's pretty much
what YouTube was that's what it was the
very first thing I used to YouTube for
was looking at old music performances
right like people put all these things
online that was great people you
couldn't see live suddenly you could see
on YouTube and my mom used to send me
guitar videos of people that she would
find online or music videos same thing
right right so uh but that's pretty much
what I used YouTube for people complain
about the internet in a lot of ways in
social media and how it's denigrating
Society or dragging us down but there's
just so much good in it that I I can't
really get on the side of complaining
it's a balance but but there's a lot of
good going on I agree and so how did it
happen I mean I think I know the answer
to this story but uh how did you get
into making YouTube videos about music
so I had this intern name Rhett shawl
Rhett is now a YouTuber himself he's a
guitar player he was uh had been
interning with me since probably 2013 or
so and I'd started my channel in 2016
almost exactly six years ago it was June
8th I made my first video of 2016. and
uh in December of 2015 I did a video
um a friend of mine asked me to make a
video of my son a guy that a guy named
um
Shane that I was producing a country
artist and I my son Dylan I was saying
oh Dylan's got Perfect Pitch I played
these really complex scores and she's
like oh make a video of that so I can
show my wife Angie and I said okay and
so I just I put it on Facebook on my
personal Facebook
sent Shane a link and I went off to my
um I was on the school board at my kid's
school went after my school board
meeting and I came back and Shane says
uh that video you put up it's got 5 000
views I said what like on Facebook he
says I think it's a viral video I said
no way and the next day he calls me in
the morning he says it's got 22 000
views I said some believable then by the
next by that night I had a million and
it was getting you know 10 000 views a
minute and stuff and got 20 something
million 23 million views something like
that and uh but that was on Facebook and
Facebook at that time was kind of like
uh like Tic Tac is now you know you
could have these really massive viral
videos and and
so we did a couple couple videos like
that and six months later is when Rhett
suggested me said you should you should
be a YouTuber and I was like what
nobody's gonna watch a white-haired guy
with on YouTube
and uh I want to make videos about make
music theory you know history whatever
film scoring whatever you and and that's
what I started doing so I you know I
started with music theory and nothing to
do with with music production or rock
music or pop music or anything that that
I had been making my living at for the
last 20 years it was all stuff when I
was a college professor in my 20s I
taught Jazz studies I have a master's in
master's degree from New England
Conservatory and Jazz studies I have an
undergraduate degree in classical base
so I have a pretty wide
knowledge base from all different types
of music all different genres and um
so that's kind of how I started I just
started with one video and just kept
making them now I'm up to a thousand
videos and that a thousand videos I
cannot even imagine I'm up to a little
over 200 podcasts it's just exhausting
so kudos to you exactly doing the video
thing
um but but the feature the subject
matter of that first video is kind of
interesting right why did it become
viral is it just because people are
fascinated by the idea of Perfect Pitch
maybe you should remind us what perfect
[ __ ] is for those who are not music
experts Perfect Pitch is to when the
ability to identify any pitch without a
reference tone so my son Dylan can hear
a 12 note chord and tell you not only
what every note is
so quickly but he can tell you at the
time when he was eight years old you
could say oh it's you know
an e add 9 over F major you know
specifically what the notes were which
would be and the chord voicing might be
from the bottom up c f a b e f sharp G
sharp so here's this e b f sharp G sharp
that's e add 9 in inversion and then F
major is in inversion c f a and the the
fact that he could listen to it he could
pick it out separate the two things and
name them instantly is so beyond just
regular Perfect Pitch you know because
because that involves music theory so
it's an eight-year-old kid that not only
has Perfect Pitch but he's got this he's
got the music theory part of it it has
to help but he's uh The Offspring of a
music producer professor
well yes so when I knew when I realized
he had Perfect Pitch when he was about
three and a half I thought oh I'm I'm
gonna teach Dylan music theory because
Dylan had had an incredibly good memory
too that
um I remember I did a uh I I did a thing
I said to him Dylan um he wanted me he
wanted me to buy him these cup stacking
things this thing he didn't is gym class
and I look and it's like 40 bucks for
these cups that have no Bottoms in them
and you stack them as fast as you can
and stuff
it's ridiculous it's so expensive and
he's like and he said can I do something
for it I said okay um and we had just
watched this Vsauce video about 52
factorial good and uh the amount of
possibilities of a deck of playing cards
and I go um I go Alexa what is 52
factorial and it goes 80 invigintillion
blah blah blah names this 87 digit
number and I said if you can recite this
Dylan I'll buy this for you he goes oh
no problem record it for me so I say it
again I recorded my phone he goes just
send it to me he goes his room for about
two minutes and he comes back he says
okay got it
and yeah I said no way and he recited it
but then I was like wait how do I check
I said is that right and so then I had
to listen back and then he said I'm
gonna write it down and he wrote it I've
had we had a white board in the kitchen
at the time then he wrote it down for me
the 87 digits like you know sweat and
then I recorded I'm doing I said okay
we'll make a video with me but he also
got lucky because as I recall you have a
video explaining how adults who don't
have perfect pitch cannot develop it or
just this is not going to happen it's an
early onset skill well this is my theory
anyways my theory is that people develop
it when they develop language and I call
it native music fluency because your
native language is the one that you
learn as a baby whatever languages you
learn as a baby you retain and and uh
and Perfect Pitch is the same thing but
people can learn I mean you do ear
training and music training so people
can learn things
pretty much if you're really good at it
like for having Perfect Pitch yeah okay
and then so so I guess this is what what
I want to get into is just this
intersection of Music Theory and popular
music and and the big question well let
me put it this way when I was in junior
high school uh you know we had math uh
sorry music class and we had a music
teacher Mr Bell I still remember his
name and unlike all the preview yeah
exactly all the previous unlike the
previous music teachers I had he used
pop music uh to explain what he was
talking about and he explained to us
that you know popular songs have a
structure intro Verse Chorus and there's
like the instrumental part and it every
has every group has a Rhythm Section and
then you know the lead instruments and
singers and as a budding physicist at
the time like the idea there was a
theory even at that super simple level
there's a theory of the structure for a
song totally changed the way that I
thought about music and is that a fair
sort of model for what you're trying to
spread more widely to the people out
there on YouTube
absolutely absolutely I I
try to I tried to teach people things
that uh of whatever the genre of music
is whether it's
um the structure of a song whether it's
um if it's a how to listen to a jazz
tune you know how how motifs are
repeated and developed or
I just interviewed Bernard Purdy who's a
famous uh drummer that um played with
with Aretha Franklin and Steely Dan and
and he has a drum beat called the Purdy
Shuffle that a lot of people uh Jeff
picaro from Toto use for Rosanna it's a
variation of the pretty Shuffle or John
Bonham from Led Zeppelin used it for
unfold in the rain his own version of it
and I interviewed Bernard in New York
last week and he's uh 79 years old and I
asked him about
how he miked his drums how they taped
his how he taped his drums to deaden the
overtones and then he pulled off his
high I started filming as soon as he
came in there before we even had the
camera set I'm filming on my phone he
said oh this hi-hat this is no good the
way they make the the clutch and the
hi-hat it's the thing that holds the
hi-hat to the the top symbol and uh and
he says um they these are too long now
and they produce too many overtones and
it's so fascinating to
to talk to a guy that's
uh that was around when people were
developing the sounds of how drums were
recorded from the 60s to the 70s how
they went from three microphones to six
microphones or seven microphones and
from mono to stereo and it's just it's
all part of the history of Music the
history of recording so it's all these
things I try to teach simultaneously
and it's there's the historical part of
it that's that's really important to
preserve so I mean are you a believer
that people can appreciate music
perfectly well without knowing any
Theory at all but you appreciate it in a
different way if you do is that fair
absolutely yeah yeah music touches
people in different ways I don't ever
think about the theory of a song that I
like never even occurs to me I only
think of it if I have to explain it to
someone right okay so you yourself just
don't really me myself I made a video on
the uh this song
um Josie by Steely Dan this a couple
months ago but the intro I call it the
weirdest intro of all time or something
like that and and um and I started and
the video was very short I just did the
intro and I thought well I need to break
down the whole song and I thought to
myself I've never learned this song I've
been listening to it for 45 years it's
so odd why have I never figured it out
because because I just enjoy listening
to it yeah good and then did you
discover
reasons why it was good in the process
of sort of taking it apart and thinking
about it I discovered that it was even
weirder than than uh and then I thought
I thought to myself
how would you come up with something
like that it's so there's a Randomness
to it that make that sounds so good
right the part sounds so good together
this was did not fit with any kind of
theory this is purely them experimenting
with things that they thought sounded
good together perfectly legitimate way
of doing it and I want to get into and
well let me just ask it right now do you
think that the most successful popular
songwriters and musicians uh I mean what
percentage of them know any music theory
at all versus being completely intuitive
musicians and and which what percentage
are like highly trained in that stuff
um I think that that people know a lot
more music theory they might not know
the names for them but they know how
things are put together for example
does Elton John well John this is maybe
a bad example I I did a breakdown of um
of Tiny Dancer last week and um Elton
John uses a lot of chord inversions now
does he know their Cordon versions of
course he does because he he's
he is doing them on purpose he'll play a
G7 chord with a with a B in the bass and
he moves it up to a D in the bass and he
obviously knows he's got one hands
playing the chord as gbdf and so he
plays a B in the bass and D in the bass
he knows what notes are in the chord
because he's playing it in his right
hand so he knows that these other notes
are cool bass notes to use they're
inversions so but does he say does he
know that with the B and the bass it's a
first inversion Maybe not maybe not
maybe just know what that's called it
doesn't matter he knows that it sounds
good right that's the intuition part but
he but also the progressions are very
sophisticated Sean too he's he's he goes
to all these different places using his
intuition but he has to know what the
chords are to come up with them put to
put them together too so and that
intuition is trained by the fact that we
grew up listening to music right it's
not like if you were put on a desert
island as a baby you would figure all
this out but you sort of pick up things
from the air and even if you don't like
you say you know the names for them
certain things sound good and you figure
that out yes a great thing that I know
that I learned from watching The Beatles
get back documentary was that the guys
in the band have phenomenally good
memories for example any time that they
would go into a cover song Paul
McCartney would start winner John Lennon
they would play it and they would never
make mistakes
when John Lennon went to and these are
songs that they played back in the 50s
and early 60s when they were in Hamburg
you know they learned they knew a
thousand songs
then when John Lennon would say oh this
needs an organ part he go over and sit
down at the Lowry organ they had I think
that's what they had in the video and he
didn't ask Paul McCartney what are the
chord changes he sat down and just
played the right chords and didn't make
any mistakes ever now if I'm narrating
this as the videos going on I'd be
saying some things like notice that John
Lennon just sat down at this
they're writing the song he says sound
of the keyboard he doesn't ask what the
chords are or anything he just sits and
starts playing and never makes a mistake
and the guys are just they were geniuses
yeah it's not fair I mean they were they
were pretty good the rest of us can't
always keep up but let me let me just do
a very little bit of of asking about
what music theory is or you know what it
what it sort of comes down to in modern
western music uh we there's a lot to
cover I will encourage everyone to go to
your channel because you you cover it
all and you but the it takes a long time
to get there um so I guess you know
octaves and scales are probably the very
first thing one should think about right
and I've always
had this really basic question so you
know we have an octave that makes sense
to me at the mathi level right there's a
note and there's another note with twice
the frequency but then we divide it up
into 12 intervals or 11 intervals I
guess
um yep and okay so we can do that and
it's equally spaced and there's a
logarithm in there and so I even get
that uh but then we pick out some subset
of those 11 notes and call it a scale a
major scale a minor scale a blue scale
or whatever so who says how who decides
that we should pick out those notes is
that cultural is there some deep
mathematical reason why we do that or is
it just yeah it sounds good let's not
ask too many questions
uh I when equal temperament came
uh into a common use
um so that's equal temperament is equal
spaces between the notes yeah yeah so so
during the Baroque Era um you know Bach
has these two different cycles of alter
temper clavier two books book one and
book two the first book was was written
in 1722 the second book was written in
1742 so when he was uh 37 and 57 years
old and they are there's 24 preludes and
24 fugues in each so they're in each key
and this is when you were able to play
in every key and modulate anywhere and
have the instruments not be Out Of Tune
as they would be in some of the earlier
temperaments that they have so who who
decided on this stuff
um as far as the names of what to call
them
um I mean there were early music
theorists
that um that came up with some of these
names but some of the names of the modes
were we go back to Pythagoras I believe
you know uh so
um but I guess what I'm asking is less
about the name than the specific subset
of notes that make up the major scale
right so there's some half steps and
some whole steps
and it sounds good when you play them
together you know sometimes you're going
up by a little bit sometimes you're
going up by a lot and it sounds good is
there uh an understanding of why that
sounds good or do we just you know say
this is how this sounds let's put it to
work
okay so this is interesting
um this is an interesting uh question an
interesting topic so when I was when my
girls were were young um well they're
still pretty young I was in a car and I
said let me play you something and I
played the the music to Psycho this the
slasher the shower scene
and I said what do you think that sounds
scary okay now they don't know what the
movie is they have no idea what this is
why does that sound scary well it sounds
scary because it is a cluster that's
called an X cell so it's four chromatic
notes they're not played consecutively
chromatic they're in different octave
they're dispersed in different octaves
but they give
uh because of the way the overtone
series works there's a lot of beating of
intervals right because you have these
all these close it may not be a half
step it may be a minor nine interval
which is a half step expanded so you
could be like from C to C sharp up the
octave so that would be a minor nine as
opposed to C right next to C sharp would
be a minor second interval and then
maybe you have a b in there and that's a
Major Seventh interval so you have all
these beating intervals that are beating
really quickly and it gives a very tense
sound and
it just sounds scary
and they don't know the any Theory or
anything but yeah they know that it
sounds scary to them so what does that
mean I'm not sure what that means but I
think it means that certain combinations
of notes together
have
um inherent properties that will sound
will produce a certain emotional
response from a human yeah that's
exactly what I want to do probably
differs from culture to culture it could
yeah I bet that there's both some
commonalities and some differences uh
from culture to culture because some of
the reasons why there might be
commonalities is
there is math behind it I promise
there'd be no math for physics but you
know there is the idea that notes sound
good if they're a ratio of a half or a
third or four-fifths next to each other
was if they're a ratio of 11 12 you're
going to get a little jumpy in some
sense right so so and maybe that helps
explain why
scales fit together in nice ways and if
you're teaching someone to improvise you
know just stay in the scale whatever you
play will sound pretty good right yes
that's that's you're absolutely you're
absolutely correct with that and when
we're listening okay so so this and just
tell the audience I mean what are the
scales people should know about everyone
says uh there are major scales and minor
scales is that enough or should the
semi-sophisticated pop music listener be
a little bit more knowledgeable well the
pro those are pretty much the main
scales uh that that people should know
but there are certain scales there are
modes that that are commonly used in pop
music like the mixolydian mode that most
rock songs are based on
um can you explain what it really is
mixolydian mode would be a major scale
but with a flatted seventh so in in the
if you start on C so C D E F G A B flat
C okay as opposed to B natural C so
that's a mixolydian scale and a lot of
rock chord progressions are based on the
mixolydian scale or Melodies are
um and the lydian scale is um
is another mode that's very common in
rock music
um the first part on don't on don't
stand so close to me or um every little
thing she does is Magic by the police
are both examples of of
um of Melodies that are lydian melodies
so I guess I thought maybe I'm totally
wrong about this or maybe it's
equivalent I thought that a mode was the
same set of notes but with a different
starting point rather than starting at C
major you go up but maybe if you just
shift it's equivalent it is yeah it is
it is yes so so lydian is the fourth
mode of the major scale so every every
scale there we I call them parents
scales there's really a group of parent
scales there's the major scale the minor
scales within the major scale it's the
aeolian mode is really the natural minor
scale but you have other types of minor
scales you have the melodic minor and
the harmonic minor scale then you have
the harmonic major and the double
harmonic major scale those are pretty
much the all the parent scales and all
modes are derived from those
those five different parent scales and
if you're listening to a song could you
identify what scale it is taking
advantage of yeah okay you can pretty
much just play the uh play the chord
progression you can just sing the scale
that the melody is using and know uh if
you can sing the starting note of the
base of the root note of the chord and
sing the scale you know what the what
the notes are uh are are suggest that
what what mode it comes from and again
just to be like super naive about this
there's also what key the song is in
which is a different question yeah so
the key refers to how many sharps or
flats it has and whether it's major or
minor uh there are 12 major keys and 12
minor keys
and they have a key signature associated
with them they go around this thing
called the circle of fifths so the
circle of fifths would be if you go in a
sharp direction is c g d a e b f sharp
or g flat then d flat a flat E flat
um B flat F and then you're back to C so
that's a circle of fifths and um it
starts with C has zero sharps or flats
the key of G has one sharp D major has G
major has one chirps D major is two
sharps if you go in the flat Direction F
major has one flat B flat major has two
flat C flat major has three flats and
this is just something that you commit
to memory this these are the basic
building blocks of music theory I
usually start with key centers then I
teach people
scales and how to build chords how to
build basic major minor chords and you
know same question for Keys as for
scales can you listen to a song and know
what key it's in or do you need Perfect
Pitch to be able to do that well Dylan
can tell you what key it's in but I I
can tell you that it's in a major key or
minor key or it's uh or it's in a mode
but I don't know unless I have a
reference tone I don't know the exact
key it's in although if I'm hearing a
guitar
I can pretty much tell you what key it's
in if I if I'm listening to uh to
somebody play on guitar I can tell you
what the chords are and things like that
I can recognize the the shapes of them
and that's just mostly from super duper
familiarity with playing and watching
other people play the guitar I call it a
um
it's a collection of recognized sounds
okay right it's it's a vocabulary of
recognized sounds
pitch memory tonal memory whatever we
want to call it it's it's uh you you
recognize that what a D major chord on
guitar sounds like just by hearing it or
an E minor chord or a major they just
have a certain sound to them you can
recognize the shapes and most people
that are that have played for a long
time can instantly recognize those
shapes okay okay good I got it and so
that's all the music theory I wanted to
cover mostly to inspire people to go
watch your videos and learn more details
so uh and they're not they're they're
way more interesting than what I just
described there so well you need to know
what you need to know right like you
need to learn the scales the keys uh the
chords good and the circle of fifths
very very important but uh what I want
to get into then is the connection
between these ideas and how the song
makes us feel how we react to it right
is there any sense so if I if I have a
key if a song is played in the key like
you'll often hear musicians say a you
know could we play in a different key
like my fingers don't go that way or
whatever is the feeling of the song
Changed by going to a different key
isn't it in some sense just increasing
the pitch of every note by the same
amount and some very vague understanding
that's a great question now I would say
yes and I don't have perfect pitch but I
think that certain Keys have certain
sounds to them people with perfect pitch
really say that that's the case
um certain Keys a major is a very bright
key for example or D major is a very
bright key and you know D flat minor is
a very kind of dark key or is there
certain keys that that if you try to
transpose a song to a particular key
where to me it just sounds weird I went
to see
um a
um
I won't say who the artist is a very
famous Duo from the 80s
back about four years ago or so I went
to to the show and they were playing
their hits now like I said I don't have
perfect pitch but they were playing them
tuned down so far that they didn't even
sound like the songs I couldn't even I
didn't even know what songs they were
Sean and they were these famous hits
but because of their voices because
they're older they needed to tune them
down and they just sounded so weird yeah
I think Joni Mitchell sounded better in
the 80s and 90s than in the 60s because
she lost the ability to get up so high
so uh sometimes that can work against
you but I mean it's really interesting
the the famous quote of course Nigel
toughnell in spinal tap saying the D
Minor is the saddest of all possible
keys and I I still I I
I think maybe the connection with
perfect pitch helps me understand a
little bit because whether we know it or
not it's not just the relationships and
frequency between the notes but the note
affects us somehow right and that's at
the heart of these Keys having it I
think that's true I I absolutely believe
that's true yes whether people know it
or not and everyone has a certain amount
of this pitch memory Sean that that is
uh uh they have a a feeling that's
whether they realize it or not a
subconscious feeling of these things
that that um that affects them in in
certain ways I think yeah okay good and
then okay so to again put it to use in
some sense
um if we if we know enough music theory
so we know some scales and some chords
and so forth there is there's a set of
words I hear over and over again when
you're giving your videos you do this
wonderful set of videos on what makes
this song great and
often you will hear well because we go
from Discord to this chord or we
modulate from this key to this key it
gives us a sense of excitement or
resolution or nervousness or fright or
whatever
um how systematic is that like if I said
I would like something that makes us
feel Melancholy does that translate in
your mind into a certain chord change or
or is it just you fool around to see
what makes that work both okay
I think you come up with this stuff by
seeing what makes it work but there are
certain things certain
type Melodies like there are certain
minor Keys like aeolian which is natural
minor that has a very melancholy sound
to it and the note in the natural minor
beyond the minor third of the of the
chord the flat six which is one of the
important notes of the scale that that
gives the aeolian mode or the natural
minor scale it's flavor because it leads
you down to the fifth as opposed to the
Dorian mode a Dorian Melody has a
natural six and that leads you up to the
flat seven and when you have notes that
are leading down to really strong anchor
tones in the scale the root or the fifth
of the chord so the a flat second pulls
you down to the root and and a lot of
metal
uh is uses a lot of flat two chords and
things like that it has a really strong
um pole back down to the tonic it has a
dark sound whereas a sharp four leads
you up to the fifth and a flat six leads
you down to the fifth so the sharp four
is the lit from the lydian scale has an
uplifting a Celestial sound or
otherworldly sound whereas that flat six
has a has a more Melancholy depressing
sound I think I think most people think
this too
yeah no that makes perfect sense except
um let's choose that single example that
you mentioned of the flat 2 I guess that
is useful in heavy metal
um what is that what's a flat second
flat second would be in the key of C
would be a d flat so just a half step
above the root so it's not in the major
scale right it's it's uh it's a step
below what would be the second note if
you go do re me do re it'd be I'm such a
terrible singer here if I had my guitar
I can play it for you which I do have my
guitar
so there's your dough that's not C
to D instead of that's a flat two got it
has a certain Darkness to it
um that makes me think of the Batman
song from Lego Lego Batman exactly
exactly so
um so composers use these things to to
you know evoke certain feelings uh
composed you know the film composers
they know how to use these
um
these devices these intervals within
scales that will give you
these um we'll give the listener a
certain sense of
um like I said lydian is is a is um
otherworldly or Celestial Thomas Newman
the composer great film composer he used
that I was watching a a talk that he was
giving on YouTube and um
and he said he talked about the
difference between the sharp four and
the flat two
and the sharp fours it gives you a feel
of hopefulness things like that I'm
feeling very manipulated just by these
frequencies like you know it's almost is
there a worry that making it too
mechanical to understand these things
too well I mean I think the answer is no
but I can see why people would be
concerned no and people just play the
things and then they realize every time
I use that it gives it it it has a
Celestial sound or hopeful you know and
it this is just Tools in their in their
um repertoire that that it's not there
to manipulate the listener but I guess
it is actually I think all songwriters
do that sure sure
um but but it also speaks to this idea
that you don't need to be trained in
music theory to have these feelings in
some sense I mean you talked about no
the root note of the scale right that
first note where you start and is this
connected to the concept that you raised
in some of your videos about musical
gravity like you want to come back to
that starting point it's exactly what
I'm talking about musical Gravity the
the
um
that certain uh Keys certain tones have
a want to move right have a very strong
pull to a certain pitch like in the that
like I was saying that flat 2 wants to
move down to the down to the root
and it's commonly used that way yeah and
it's interesting because it's not in the
major scale so this is you know one
thing I want to ask about was the major
scale is so common because the notes all
more or less sound pretty good together
but then you've got some interestingness
by deviating from that right by taking
something that is outside your
expectation and and that the sort of
heaviness of metal uh is one way to be
interesting in that in that context
yeah so when I I interviewed sting back
in November and sting I asked him about
the about surprise and music and he says
he goes that's funny that you use that
term he goes if if I'm not surprised
within the first eight bars I stop
listening
and the surprise meaning going someplace
that people aren't expecting right that
that's really important having some odd
note that you go to that's unpredictable
oh what is that and Joni Mitchell's a
great example of a person that just
always goes to these places that are
just whoa what wow that's amazing it's
beautiful
uh just
incredible just intuitive ear that she
had of of going to these different
modulating to different keys that you
would never expect in these beautiful
Melodies that float on top of these
incredible chord progressions that she
comes up with with these alternate
tunings and she's such a genius then she
comes up with the lyrics that work with
them yeah and and sting is the same way
I mean they just come up with these
incredible lyrics that go with these you
know all this things were eating where
it just goes to places you don't expect
and that's what I I love about music I
want to always be surprised well well
while thinking about this podcast I I
came up with a theory for the meaning of
life uh it's to you know explore little
bits of dissonance and surprise and and
chromatic things off key but then always
to resolve to the tonic that's my new
theory of what we should be doing in our
lives
there you go no that's true that's uh
you know you know always bringing it
back
you know when you go outside it's
somewhere bringing it back to the to the
home to home base is really an important
thing otherwise things don't feel like
they're complete
and of course we can overdo it so one of
my favorite videos that you have is on
the four chords that ruined pop music uh
yeah what are these chords and and how
has the ruination taken place uh the one
four five and six chords how has it
taken place because there are hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of famous
songs over the last 20 years that have
been written with this exact same chord
sequence or or variations of the same
sequence
uh you know it can be four one six five
four one five six one four five six one
five four six one six five four any of
the permutations of those four chords is
is the uh uh are the four chords that
that uh ruined pop music and we've all
seen these videos of like someone
playing this chord progression and just
singing different Melodies over it and
doing every song right that's in the top
20. exactly
and and and you don't see it as much
these days it's not used as much it was
used in all different genres of music it
was in pop it was in rock it was in
country but really from the late 90s to
um to 20 2016 2017 2018 it was just used
over and over and over and one of the
reasons I think is that people that
worked at record labels they didn't
think that songs sounded like singles if
they didn't use that chord progression
so the people that were in charge
thought
oh whether they knew it or not they
would just always think the songs that
had that chord progression sound like
hits and those would be the singles but
what I loved about that video is that
you did an experiment you collected data
you said you know let's pick some of the
most successful hit songwriters in our
lifetimes The Beatles and Max Martin who
actually I'll confess I did not know Max
Martin's name
tell us who Max Martin is he's everyone
knows who he is even if they don't know
his name he's a Swedish composer that uh
pop songwriter producer that said I'm
not sure how many number one hits he's
had now probably in the high 20s or so
maybe 30 but he's not the artist he
gives these to other people and so we we
all know Max Martin songs but we don't
know that they are Max Martin songs if
we're not that's right and and uh and he
has very few songs that use that chord
progression as the Beatles did I think
that uh The Beatles had only one song of
their 27 number one songs which was let
it be that had the one four five and six
and even let it be used other a few
other chords Beyond those
so it's not that you need to use those
chords to make a hit clearly if beetles
and Martin didn't do it but so you're
saying this is more commentary on the
music industry than it is on music
theory correct
and is this a lesson for young
songwriters like should they try to
March to the beat of their own drummer
as it were and to use a different chord
progression yeah and I think that people
have moved on from that now finally I
almost need to make a video about yeah
about that have we seen the end of one
four five six and and
I I haven't heard you know I'm not
hearing it a lot and maybe when I hear
it again I'll be I'll think to myself
wow it's nice to hear that again
it reminds me that there's one music
theory-esque question that I had so as a
very naive music person someone who
loves it but doesn't know a lot to me
the first thing is actually a melody in
a song and but I I whenever you talk to
musicians they're always about the chord
progression and if I just knew the
melody could I figure out what the chord
progression is or is that an extra thing
that is added in the particular track no
you cannot figure out the chord
progression from the melody
unless it's Bach or Beethoven or or a
classical depends what the melody is but
usually for pop songs you can't tell
what the chord progression is
necessarily
uh because there's a lot of different
possibilities but but there's a
relationship you know you want to be
singing songs that are either in or
close to those chords or I don't know
I'm making this up yeah yeah I mean it
depends on the song I mean some songs uh
some songs really describe the chord
progression it depends on the song I
guess some songs really describe the
chord progression in the melody very
clearly
um a song that doesn't do it for example
is Smells Like Teen Spirit which has an
incredibly sophisticated Melody but it
doesn't necessarily spell out the chords
uh whereas
um well I mean a song like Norwegian
would by The Beatles John Lennon's song
is um is in one scale so it really
spells out
okay the scale
um it's in the mixolydian mode
um and it spells it out with the guitar
part and with the vocal Melody does it
mean in principle that I could have the
same Melody over a different chord
progression yes absolutely and people do
that well re it's called reharmonization
you take a melody and you just put
different chords under it ah okay good I
did not know that was allowed uh yes
that's really loud and jazz players do
it all the time
they do lots of crazy things I mean I
love it but it is is it just a
stereotype or is it true that there's a
slightly higher level of musical
sophistication for a typical jazz song
for than for a rock song usually yes yes
there's there's um depends
um on what rock song but well a lot of
most jazz songs have more sophisticated
chord progressions and Melodies than
rock songs okay I'm glad that we were
able to uh verify my prejudices along
those lines
um yeah you know I wanted to get into uh
it's interesting because this is I
presume that this is most of what you do
now making YouTube videos rather than uh
okay uh so there are some videos that
are going to be more popular than others
and I love the music theory explanations
but uh there's a great demand out there
for top 10 lists you know best guitar
solos of all time and and so forth so
you do mix that in do you have like a an
agenda when you do that are you trying
to teach people along with just making a
provocative list or is it just like I
think this is fun let's just go for it I
use those lists to expose people to
things that they would never heard I
always put things that are
out in left field that would never be on
a top 20 or top 10 list
I did uh I just did a video at the top
20 strangest guitar solos ever and it
was basically an excuse to expose people
to to weird guitar solos by
players that they would normally hear
like Alan Holdsworth was one of the
people who's a really he Alan passed
away in 2016 but it was a really
sophisticated
right you know uh progressive rock
guitarist and instrumentalist and
amazing guitar virtuoso and had really
weird song structures and very very
Advanced chord progressions that he
would improvise over and so it was my
excuse to expose people to people like
Alan Holdsworth and the few of the
people that I put in there that are out
in left field I use the video to draw
people in and then expose them to things
that they wouldn't normally hear good I
think that's a great I have the same
philosophy of my podcast try to mix in
big names with people you've never heard
of before
um right but but the other you know
genre of video that you come out with
that I love that I've already mentioned
or the what makes this song great videos
and one of the things I just gotta ask
while I have you here you're often
saying oh let's just play the drum track
or the the vacuum vocals like where do
you get these individual tracks is there
technology that will isolate them or do
you just know people who know people
uh there are some technologies that I
that you can isolate some things if they
are panned to the side or they're right
in the center of the stereo image there
are pieces of software that will
separate them but I typically will get
them if the artist is in the video I get
them from the artist I mean I had Brian
May in my Bohemian Rhapsody video people
say where'd you get the track the
Bohemian Rhapsody um from Brian Mays in
the video
I did I had a video on Kiss From A Rose
and seal is in the video where did you
get the tractions Kiss From A Rose
um from seal he's in the video that's
okay you know so um but pretty much all
the ones that I play on that series are
multi-tracks that I've or stems which
are usually stereo versions of like the
drums there'll be a guitar stem or the
left and right and and they're just
things that people have given to me over
the years you do know that Brian may
also has a PHD in astrophysics right I
do yes yes just like me so we have that
in common he's better at playing the
guitar than I am but uh we have
something I love that about Brian yeah
he's done done uh serious astrophysical
research it's pretty awesome
um so from doing these
what makes this song great videos let me
sort of re-ask the question that I that
I alluded to earlier uh these are all
songs you think are great and one of the
great things is about it is you're
pretty ecumenical when it comes to genre
like you'll do folk songs in heavy metal
and progressive rock and whatever do you
find yourself liking the songs even more
or discovering things about them when
you sort of analyze them at this
slightly more conscious level than just
grooving to them
so so here's this is something I'd like
to tell people I don't say it that often
but when I say what makes the sun great
I have a question mark in the title and
and the reason I have the question mark
is that not every single song that I've
analyzed I think is necessarily a great
song it's it's why I think other people
think it's a great song okay even though
in general
99 of the songs I think are great songs
or 95 of the songs I do and are I think
are are great songs but it's really more
answering the question why do people
think that this is a great song why is
this a hit song
that makes perfect sense you know when I
read someone like Dan Brown who wrote
The Da Vinci Code uh you know I don't
think he's a great writer in the sense
of what I look for in a writer but he's
got getting something right right he's
appealing to some people and that's a
talent that's a skill he's doing
something really really well right it's
exactly right and however I do want to
say it was just before we did this
listening to the video that you did
about comfortably numb and I don't think
you were faking your enthusiasm for that
one you seem to you seemed to be very
genuine no no no no no no no no no like
I said 95 98 of the songs that I do are
songs I really love
and since you're there uh I mean you're
you have been a music producer a
musician and music Professor talk a
little bit about the way a song gets
made in in pop music especially let's
say like now versus 20 years ago versus
40 years ago uh I get the feeling it's
not someone an artist who is at home
with a guitar writes a song and then
brings it in teaches it to the band and
they record it that day like it's a
little bit there's more moving Parts
these days yeah that's correct yeah that
used to be how it was done is that they
would when I started that's what it
would be you'd show it to your band and
you'd rehearse it you come up with an
arrangement and then if you were had
enough money you could go in a recording
studio and if you had even more money
you go get hire a producer
and you would record it and um nowadays
people can open up their laptop and you
know get a Daw with a um
some type of a Daw interface digital uh
analog to digital interface
and record all the parts you know with
simulated amplifiers simulated drum you
know drum samples and uh and keyboards
and pretty much do everything in a
laptop plug the mic into the into the uh
Daw into your converter and do your
vocals and you can pretty much do
everything in computers it seems like
guitars or stringed instruments more
generally would be harder to do in that
way like if I just yeah gave a computer
a musical score it could play the piano
part or the drums right yeah guitar is
harder to to
um harder to do a digital version of but
um you can get samples that are you know
are pre-recorded
sections and pieced together a guitar
part like that and so is it so okay so
you can do that now uh the computers are
helping us do this yep it would seem to
me that there's sort of two directions
that pulls Us in on the one hand maybe
it takes us away from the organic uh
Soulful side of people playing their
instruments or even the sort of
um virtual virtuoso side of people
playing their instruments really really
well since anyone can do it and ask the
computer do it on the other hand it
sounds like it's a democratizing
influence where anyone can make an album
which I think is great so I don't know
where do you come down there
um well I wouldn't be able to I wouldn't
be talking to you right now if it
weren't for computers and Daws because
the only way I was able to become a
producer at 37 was that they uh did you
design invented Pro Tools with the inner
digi001 interface and I was able to
purchase one for 1200 bucks and learn
the software I couldn't have gone as a
37 year old to a studio an intern for
two years to learn how to become a
producer and how to engineer things I
taught myself taught myself how to edit
and digital audio workstations and then
that eventually led me to be able to
learn how to edit video and make videos
because you edit videos just like you
edit audio and matter of fact you use
the waveforms the audio waveforms to
know where you are
just like editing a podcast you look at
the waveforms and and you know where to
make Cuts so you do think that there is
some positive effect of this but but
presumably there's a negative effects of
too much technology creeping into the
making of Music also yeah uh
people don't really have to be
um virtuosos on instruments anymore you
don't have to hire session players if
you don't want to
um the fact that you can fix any
performance
and don't have to play anything in real
time
makes it to where anyone can do it but
the fact that anyone can do it kind of
makes it maybe not as special I don't
know that's that's a debate to have yeah
well you give a couple examples in your
videos
um with auto-tune which can fix the
pitch of singers and then also with
quantization of drum beats and you know
I say that only reluctantly because
quantization means something very
different to physicists than it does to
music producers uh but in both cases
you're sort of like rubbing off the
rough edges right you're uh making
something a little bit perfect which
takes away some of the meaning of it or
is that just us being grumpy old men you
know is it is it uh good to be more
perfect or is it uh
making it too similar and clean and
therefore not as exciting
well it kind of depends on what it is
you know people have been using drum
machines since the 80s and some of my
favorite songs have drum machines on
them Tears for Fears and a lot of 80s
music when drum machines first came out
the songs that I really love use drum
machines Tom Petty used drum machines on
some of his big songs he used drum
machines he also used real drummers
um and I'm not going to say that that
you know no auto-tune you know uses but
you know there's nothing that's nothing
that's good about autotune I saved many
of performances by having auto-tune on
records I produced were the vocal
vocalist wasn't here it just couldn't
hit a pitch and
I would have a take that the tone of it
was great but the pitch might have been
off on a line on a couple notes
and it was way easier to fix those and
have the exciting performance and get it
and have those notes be more in tune
than using a worse performance that was
more in tune so it really comes down to
the trade-off but in the in the case of
the drum beats I mean I think it's a
very specific example of the question
that I have in mind you know we have in
mind the idea that the perfect drummer
will be just exactly on time right like
the same amount of interval between
every two beats in the measure or
whatever it is and so what could be bad
about fixing that because real drummers
are not you know John Bonham was not
exactly uh marching to a metronome but
during most of those Led Zeppelin songs
no so so I find that the the the the
human element of these great drummers I
just interviewed Bernard Purdy and he
had a drum beat called the Purdy Shuffle
that uh they use in um Steely Dan song
home at last and sisters of Babylon
Bernard just has such an incredible
groove and and shuffles are based on
triplets
and it's almost impossible to do a great
Shuffle as a program a great Shuffle to
where it feels really good because
there's so many Dynamics in it and the
having that triplet feel when it's so
rigid that it's got no variance it just
sounds weird to me it sounds really
unnatural straight rock beats though are
you know when they've been quantized and
things like that people don't notice
them as much it's just like like a drum
machine so you know it's it's not always
bad but when people say I made a video
about this song called sucker by the
Jonas Brothers and there was a New York
Times reviewer saying how how the this
was such a great Groove and I was the
contrarian on it and I said it's not
really a Groove it's been quantized and
I chopped up I chopped up the thing and
I changed the tempo to show that it was
all quantized onto the 16th note on a
grid
which is why I could change the tempo
and change the timing of the song I can
make it faster or slower because it was
perfectly edited to a grid so there was
really wasn't a groove it was wasn't at
least not a human Groove you know
there's a quote that I love from I think
it's Francis Bacon who says there's no
excellent beauty that has not some
strangeness in the proportion I mean I
think I think this is what it's getting
at both from the dissonance stuff when
we were talking about Melody and Harmony
and and from the groove like it's if
it's too clean and too crisp and too
predictable it's not what we find really
beautiful yeah I I do find though that
people nowadays have been listening to
quantized music so for so long for a
generation that that anything that's not
quantized they notice
um
uh and uh and I and there's a lot of
singers that when that mimic auto-tune
and there's regulars and they mimic the
weird
um whatever you would call distorted in
computer-y I know anomalies of auto-tune
that uh uh the the the weird the pitch
bends that auto-tune does where you
think wait did you have autotune in your
voice no that's that's me singing
they're just mimicking it it's really
amazing well an artifact yeah all of
these um
changes in how music is made uh well
actually let me let me there's one
follow-up question there which is
it sounds because I recently did an
economics podcast it sounds like a
market opportunity right like if
everyone is doing drum machines and
auto-tune then is there going to be sort
of a a new place for more authentic
acoustic uh slightly messy and imperfect
musicians absolutely and there is plenty
of Indie music that's out there that's
not perfect and and that a lot of people
like and and that um I that I like to
listen to
um but it's hard to make generalizations
on
um on genres of music or certain pieces
you know there's things that are
perfectly quantized that I love the
sound of
um so but it's kind of a when every song
is expected to be like this and and it
started in the early 2000s with rock
music I think that this is a thing that
that really helped
uh limit the appeal of rock music was
the tuning and the and the quantizing of
it that um that that made Rock lose its
Edge well this is going to be my very
next question uh following up on the
title of one of your music videos is
rock music dead and why
um it's certain types of rock music are
very much alive and um progressive metal
music is very uh very much alive and
I've made a lot of videos with a lot of
the people that are the kind of the
leaders of the progressive metal
movement which is
guys like um toast and Abbasi from
Animals As Leaders Tim Henson who's in
polyphia okay Pliny is a guitarist from
Australia who's a fantastic guitarist
Aaron Marshall from intervals I've had
these people
on my channel many times I talk about
their I talk about a lot of these
progressive metal bands and and
um that's a very vibrant movement all
the people know each other they all
support each other and I I just love it
I think it's incredibly Innovative and I
um and they're they're just Reinventing
a lot of you know from the types of
instruments there's a lot of extended
range instruments seven strings eight
strings that are used nine strings and I
find it really refreshing so it's so
it's not dead it's just dead to the
there's no Van Halen's anymore there's
no rock bands that are massively big all
over the world or not really not many
that aren't in their 50s
the top 20 uh whatever list you have on
Spotify or whatever is not going to be
many recognizable rock and roll bands
these correct and but I mean is that
mostly technological because you also
seem to suggest that it had some of the
effect came from wandering away from the
blues-based roots of this music and and
into something else yeah I think that
when Rock lost the blues that people
became disinterested in in it when there
were no Blues based Melodies and the
last
uh you started seeing Blues disappear
from rock music in the early 2000s in
new metal there's a lot of great new
metal music but the last people that
used that had a lot of Blues based I
mean and yet people like Jack White with
white stripes that use blue but but in
general
the last
movement of music that was a rock bass
that used a lot of Blues inflections was
grunge and that's 30 years ago now made
me feel so Advanced like sound garden
and Pearl Jam and Nirvana and Allison
Chains and they used a lot of Blues
based Melodies and blues and blues
inflections a lot of pentatonic
um riffs things like that so
um once that once we moved away from
that in the new metal era I think people
started become disconnected from them
and that happened with autotune happened
in 2000 right when new metal got really
huge so you had you had quantizing you
had auto-tune and you had bluesless
Melodies well I guess that's what I I
have no idea what the answer to this is
I'm trying to figure out whether or not
there's a connection between these
technological changes and to move away
from the blues so I'm willing to buy
your hypothesis that moving away from
the blues has let has made rock music
either less compelling or pop music less
Rocky or something like that but is that
because of the new technologies or is
this just things that happen at the same
time coincidentally I'm not sure yeah it
could be both it's an interesting
question though they why did they
coincide
uh that's a great question I mean maybe
there's a different Spirit to it so I'm
just making things up now speculating
but you know that when you say the blues
there's a very specific
musicological I mean I mean I mean I
mean notes that are bent I mean notes
that are not that are under the pitch uh
you know things are using microtones
that right right but all these are
deviations from Perfection right correct
yes yeah and and just the words
they called Perfection sure sure but um
Blue Notes right in yeah the broadest
sense sort of are the ones that don't
fit into the scale you're playing
um but we also have this picture of like
sitting in a garage or in a run-down
Saloon or at the crossroads and just
[ __ ] with your guitar and you know a
tiny little drum kit and uh it's very
far removed from sitting in a
computerized workstation and and laying
down some beats so it sounds like
there's both a musicological difference
and also a stylistic spiritual
difference between the two approaches
exactly totally totally uh totally right
on with that and with that what do you
think is going to be what happens next
are you able to predict the future of
popular music I know that you do these
wonderful things for like every so often
you check in with the Spotify top 20 and
go like what is going on here like this
so you you say that like the title is
always like I rant about the Spotify top
10 but you often like the songs actually
I do and my much to people's to most
people dismay I like the songs I just
put out a video
called Jimi Hendrix wouldn't be famous
today okay uh just before I came I put
it out a couple hours ago and
um I haven't looked at any of the
comments but it's it's the video is
doing really well right now
which to me leads to leads me to believe
that people agree with with this that
Jimi Hendrix if he came out today no one
would pay attention I'd be interesting
to see the demographics on the views of
that video is it just folks in their 50s
and 60s like yes those kids today don't
understand real music no it probably is
a really
um much like my channel my biggest
demographics is 25 to 34 on my channel
oh very interesting and this is uh so
this will be people commenting from that
are probably all different
from all different Generations good I I
will check that out yeah so um I don't
know what they're saying but it from the
looks of it it looks like people are um
agreeing with my with my print it wasn't
my premise it was um it was from an
interview I I was I did an interview
with a bass player named Jeff Berlin in
2017 and I was at the beach this weekend
with my family and for some reason this
video
popped into my head this thing that he
said and he said in the 70s if you were
a great player you'd be you'd be famous
and and that's just not the case anymore
and I started thinking yeah the rise of
the famous soloists was really a lot of
it happened in the 70s
70s and then the 80s and then after that
the famous instrumental soloists you
know even
people in bands the Eddie Van Halen's
happened in the 70s you know the the
kind of the bands that had virtuosos in
them are gone to a certain degree well
and yet some of the greatest virtuosos
are here today but they're just not we
don't know that's right I mean even the
grunge bands that you mentioned they
were they were Blues based but they were
not uh characterized by amazing
virtuosity I mean Dave Grohl turns out
to be a wonderful musician but that
wasn't the point of no one Dave Grohl
was actually actually a virtuoso drummer
that
um people didn't realize was a very odd
well I did but uh and I mean that you
know that oh I realized it was a great
drummer I could tell he was a phenomenal
drummer
um the guys were virtuosa singers as far
as I'm concerned including Kurt Cobain
but but but uh Chris Cornell was a
virtuo so he's one of the greatest rock
singers that ever lived yeah
um so the virtuosity went to the vocals
in the in the grunge era apparently
enough well you know I always like to
end up on a hopeful or optimistic note
or at least a useful note uh I mean
obviously with you it's too easy to say
people should check out your videos but
I mean maybe is there a sales pitch for
the music lover on the street to become
a bit more knowledgeable about what goes
on in the songs whether it's really
music theory or just you know listening
for chord changes that resolve in
interesting ways uh what why should we
bother to put in that little bit of
extra effort rather than just putting on
random on our playlist and getting on
with our day I think it makes you know
if you know a little bit more about
music it makes it more enjoyable
uh you can actually appreciate it on a
different level if you understand how
it's constructed just like you said
about your your teacher that talked
about the form of Music the intro the
verse the pre-chorus the chorus the
bridge the solo the interlude whatever
and knowing those terms and then you
start listening to songs and you can
talk to your friends about them that's
really what music theory is music theory
is just the ability to talk to put terms
to to things you know and so you can
talk about them well you're not
listening to the music yeah I mean I
guess that's a very nice way of putting
it because music is very Universal
everyone can enjoy it but then to talk
to other people about it you need to be
able to put words to what is causing or
what is it what is behind that
particular sensation you got with that
drum field or whatever it is yeah yeah
grumpville or if you say hey Sean do you
what do you think about the chorus on
that song well you know what the chorus
is it's the usually the title of the
song oh I love that chorus if you say
what is a chorus you know knowing what a
chorus is is is is is
important in to in being able to talk
about this it's it's uh if you want to
talk about a song you need to be able to
talk about the different sections and
know what they are so that that's music
theory basically yeah no I like it
that's it's a great it's a communication
device and you've done as much as anyone
in in recent years to help people
understand that so Rick piato thanks so
much for being on the mindscape podcast
thanks John appreciate it
[Music]
la la
[Music]